Bon, le bus arrive dans 6 minutes,
on est parfaitement dans les temps.
Super ...
T'as cours de Maths ce matin ?
Ouais.
Vous faites quoi en ce moment,
de l'algèbre ou de la géométrie ?
Jsais pas.
Moi j'étais nulle en maths.
Ok.
Plus que 5 minutes.
Pourquoi tu me parles pas ?
Je te parle.
Ben non, tu me parles pas.
Ben si je te parle,
c'est bon.
Bon.
Oh non Maman, s'il te plait,
ça c'est relou.
Reprenons.
T'as quoi comme cours ce matin ?
Je sais pas.
"Qu'est-ce que
ça peut te foutre ?"
Ok.  T'as prévu de manger
à la cantine ce midi ?
Ouais, surement.
"Plus nul comme question,
c'est possible ?"
Qu'est-ce que tu fais
sur ton portable ?
Rien, je fais rien.
"Je poste un tweet :"
"RT si ta mère te casse les couilles
en attendant le bus"
" #mère #relou #couilles"
Ah donc je te casse les couilles.
Mais non, c'est pas ça.
"Ah si, complètement.
#deouf"
Et ben je sais pas,
parle-moi d'un truc qui t'intéresse.
Ben n'importe quoi,
qu'est-ce qui t'intÝresse ?
Jsais pas.
"Fumer des joints,
jouer à Neknomination,"
"envoyer des snapchats de ma teub
à des meufs,"
"me branler sur du porno allemand
sur Xhamster."
Ouais non, stop,
tu peux éteindre ton truc là ?
Non mais l'interromps pas,
c'est très instructif Rémy.
"Déjà t'arrêtes de m'appeler Rémy,
c'est un prénom de boloss."
"Tout le monde m'appelle K4D4VR3."
Putain mais pourquoi
t'as pris cette appli là?
Parce que tu me parles pas,
tu voulais que je fasse quoi ?
Ben je sais pas,
tu pourrais me laisser tranquille ?
Arrêter de me péter les couilles
avec tes questions à la con.
Si je te parle pas
c'est qu'il y a une raison peut-être.
Tu saoules à la fin.
"Euh ben !
Pareil."
Et puis tu fais pitiÝ avec ton appli.
Moi aussi je peux la lancer.
Pourquoi tu veux tout savoir tout le temps ?
Pourquoi tu veux
absolument me parler ?
Je sais pas.
"Parce que je suis ta mère
et que je t'aime."
"#malaise"